[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en non seulement non seulement je vais
parler aux droitiers contrarié parce que
j'en suis un et puis en même temps
comment c'est un ted en étant contrarié
c'est toujours très bien alors pour pour
être contrarié c'est pas très compliqué
fait d'événements contrariants
par exemple à l'âge de 4 ans je suis
passé sous un tracteur tondeuse et c'est
mon père qui le conduisait alors j'ai
perdu la main droite
la lame fortement agressé mon genou
droit et vous savez j'en ai jamais voulu
à mon père jamais parce que je suis en
vie je suis sur mes jambes et droitier
contrarié alors j'ai eu de la chance
parce que mes parents et mes frères et
soeurs
tout cela ou en faire une vie géniale
j'ai tout fait j'ai fait du ski du vélo
de l'agro france j'ai même fait du
cheval est d'ailleurs à l'âge de 14 ans
je suis tombé de cheval triple fracture
de l'humérus gauche contre orient alors
mon corps est couvert de cicatrices sa
jambe droite a été opéré dix fois et il
restait de l'ombre mois en hôpitaux ou
allongés il a même attrapé un
staphylocoque doré et j'ai détesté mon
corps longtemps et en détestant j'ai
détesté mon âme
j'étais persuadé qu'une à moosch était
contenue dans un corps moche et vous
savez cette extrêmement contrarié en de
penser ça à tel point qu'en 2003 au bout
de ma tête et dans mon corps j'ai songé
à l'irrémédiable mais ce jour là le
train n'est jamais passé
quelqu'un avait eu la même idée que moi
5 km avant alors ça si c'est pas hyper
contrariant tant que la vie vous fait un
pionnier pareil
alors bon je me suis cherché mes parents
donné dit ton métier il faut que tulle m
est ce que tu vas le faire longtemps
quand même alors je me suis cherché
longtemps et je me suis réveillé un peu
tard
il aura fallu une photo une seule
en 2007 j'avais 33 ans et je suis parti
à la réunion pour restructuration
personnel enfin de ressaut modo
comprenait un énorme burn out
juste avant de prendre l'avion mon père
m'a dit tiens tu verra peut-être le
rayon vert là bas alors le rayon vert
c'est un roman sentimental de jules
verne publié en 1882 et qui parle du
phénomène optique éponyme le rayon vert
lance remet en jeu l'hiver ont écrit une
vieille légende écossaise qui dit que
celui qui l'a vu la plus de problème de
sentiments qui détruit tout mensonge et
illusions et que quand on a la chance de
l'apercevoir on voit vrai dans son coeur
et dans celui des autres alors banco je
me dis ça me va sauf que là-bas bain de
soleil et les capricieux donc
contrariant alors je me suis remémoré ce
que mon père m'avait dit et puis dans
mon for intérieur je me disais non mais
je la verrai je le prendrais j'étais
très optimiste est aussi très très
prétentieux parce que les jours passent
et adrian vers le centième jour toujours
rien ça va le soleil est très propre à
steene ateurs un certain moment elle
s'enraye m joueurs désabusés
je descends sur la plage avec mon
appareil photo contre mon bras et que
l'ail et lampes et lits dame qui dit et
je crois qu'on va le voir ce soir sans y
croire je dégaine appareil photo je fais
une rafale et ça n'est que le lendemain
sur mon ordinateur
je prends le rayon vert je rentrais dans
un club d'une petite centaine de
personnes à avoir réussi cet exploit
et vous savez quoi ça fait énormément de
bien
j'étais plus contrarié j'étais
euphorique
alors je rentrais en france
métropolitaine avec la ferme intention
de faire des photos que je voulais faire
j'étais près j'étais indestructible
j'avais un thème est plus qu'un thème
une obsession le corps et l'âme et pour
cela j'ai eu deux axes le portrait et la
femme
le portrait parce que tout simplement je
suis fasciné par le regard des gens ça
dégage tellement de choses ici c'est une
photo de mon père avec son chien
ils ont le même regard
ils ont la même inclinaison de tête et
cette photo me fait sourire parce qu'ils
sont heureux ils sont heureux de faire
ce portrait est heureux de qui ils sont
surtout mon père pour la femme c'est un
peu différent
je voulais du beau du magnifique du
mystérieux mais aussi de la douleur je
voulais provoquer du désir et du drame
en même temps je voulais réaliser une
histoire sur l'âme sur la schizophrénie
sur la fin on oublie mais aussi sur
l'espoir parce que ces choses sont au
fond de nous
c'était un exutoire nécessaire pendant
six ans je n'ai fait expulser mes
angoisses et les contrariétés les
portraits des femmes des portraits des
fans portrait des femmes
je me demandais c'était vraiment un
remède pour l'âme
[Musique]
cinq ans plus tard en novembre 2012 avec
mon meilleur ami nous regardons une fois
de plus de trop
je ne sais plus l'empiré contre attaque
luke skywalker se fait remettre une main
droite après que son père l'a lu et
trancher vous allez me dire ce une
histoire un peu connu et donc je regarde
sur le net et je me dis tiens qu'est-ce
qui se vendent entre tazi et je tombe
sur une vidéo de nigella claude qui est
baroudeur binic et qui fait ses lacets
de chaussures avec une prothèse là je
suis bouche bée
j'ai une sorte de révolution qui se
créent dans ma tête je disais pourquoi
pas moi alors
j'appelle ma mère pas mon père car
malheureusement absent pour cause de
décès jamais rappelle mon médecin
mon médecin m'a pas nous il fait 10 mois
d'un passeport valide
moi je dis oui c'est bon bah écoute on
part en angleterre j'ai pris des billets
d'avion j'ai réservé des chambres
d'hôtel
on valide on va aller l'attesté cette
prothèse c'est mon cadeau je reste
pantois devant tant de générosité et une
nouvelle contrariété se profile et si ça
marche
voilà entre cette vidéo entre cette
vidéo et l'acquisition de la nouvelle
main il s'est passé quatre mois quatre
mois pour trouver un financement
parce que la sécurité sociale ne
rembourse ni la main ni les capteurs mis
les batteries ni la promo supination
alors oui moi moi j'arrive à faire un
360 degrés avec ma main pas vous c'est
contrariant
alors pour financer j'opte pour une
solution de mendiants d'après ma mère le
fonds participatif
or qu'est-ce que c'est le fond
participatif c'est très simple c'est un
projet que vous lancer sur internet
c'est des internautes sont là pour le
financer alors je pars à l'aventuré nous
disons que d'autres l'ont déjà fait pour
des créations artistiques ou des projets
professionnels
je tombe sur à l'époque la seule
plateforme qui s'occupe du social du
développement durable et bien sûr du
handicap
ils ont été d'une aide extrêmement
précieuse pour donner des conseils
incroyable ils ont vraiment soutenu le
projet le 13 décembre 2013
la plateforme est lancé j'y crois sans y
croire je vais poster sur les réseaux
sociaux
je sollicite la presse régionale et les
médias nationaux sont emparés là c'est
l'effet boule de neige
la somme de trente mille euros est
atteinte en 70 jours au lieu de 90 et je
peux vous assurer que c'est quelque
chose qui vous redonne foi mais vraiment
foi en l'humanité
alors il s'est passé beaucoup de choses
aussi dans cette période où célèbre
agence de presse m'a contacté pour faire
un documentaire sur les prothèses
bioniques
j'ai beaucoup voyagé je suis allé
partout en france en angleterre aux
etats unis
c'était très fatigant mais pas du tout
contrariant j'étais encore très haut
foriic de cette expérience
j'ai aussi une rencontre magnifique ont
donné une opportunité photographique
incroyable je me suis retrouvé programmé
au festival d'avignon cette exposition
la lumière est une immense photo de 16
mètres de long sur trois mètres de haut
encaisser dans un couloir dans le noir
qui parle des métiers de la technique et
du spectacle sur cette photo il y en a
400 prises sur dix mille photos vous
rentrez avec une lumière frontale n'est
plus de sens plus de temps pluvieux plus
d espace et à partir du moment où vous
sortez de ce couloir à la lumière c'est
une véritable délivrance
c'est un travail qui m'a pris beaucoup
de temps comme pour la prothèse alors
j'étais un conflit presque parce que
j'avais encore des contrariétés était
chanceux ou pas et est manchot ou pas et
elle je handicapés ou pas il ya beaucoup
de préjugés sur ce terme handicapés
avant j'étais juste handicapés et
maintenant je suis handicapé bionique
avant des enfants quand ils venaient me
posais une question pour savoir ce qui
m'était arrivé il y avait des parents
qui arrivent et qui l'a rattrapé par le
col et qui disent non mais embête pas de
monsieur alors que maintenant c'est les
parents qui viennent qui sont stupéfaits
par la technologie parce que ça vient du
cinoche ça vient des bd etc
[Musique]
par contre les enfants dont un peu peur
même
c'est contrariant alors que ce soit
clair ce qui nous définit c'est pas
notre handicap ce qui nous définit c'est
ce que nous faisons
ce sont nos actes alors je repense
souvent à mon accident
d'ailleurs je le rêve quotidiennement et
cette lame qui sabrent m'a fait
réfléchir sur la violence des actes sur
les accidents et vous savez tout ça
n'enlève jamais la beauté des gens et
c'est comme ça que j'ai rencontré
charlotte charlotte a le même handicap
que moi sauf que elle c'est une agénésie
de naissance en première fois je me
retrouver face à un miroir humain parce
qu'elle sait la main gauche elle
mangeait comme moi avant elle faisait
ses lacets comme moi avant de passer son
bras contre son ventre comme moi avant
et je me suis soudain rendu compte que
je ne savais plus comment j'étais avant
avant la prothèse si vous pensez que
j'étais contrarié à ce moment là eh bien
pas du tout j'étais exalté parce qu'il
fallait que je grave ça en photo une
fallait que je montre cette innocence
perdue et que je casse les préjugés sur
le handicap parce qu'il en faut de
l'innocence pour ne pas avoir de
jugement sur un corps morcelé
parce qu'il faut être innocent tous se
connecter grâce à cette collaboration
sur les gestes sur les parties
manquantes sur les partis un petit peu
présente
je livrais mon travail le plus personnel
et en même temps le plus universel et
j'ai gagné
chose je gagnais l'amitié de charlotte
on entièreté retrouver et en même temps
une p incroyable maintenant je suis un
peu comme vous tous j'accepte mes
faiblesses
j'accepte de vieillir comme vous
j'accepte d'avoir les cheveux blancs et
d'être un peu en surpoids comme certains
d'entre vous j'accepte d'être un hybride
à demain dans une fosse comme très peu
d'entre vous je pense et j'accepte
d'être capable du pire comme du meilleur
j'accepte d'avoir ni haine ni regrets ni
rancoeur car ce sont des poisons violent
ce qui est important c'est l'avenir et
c'est que l'on en fait avec ce que l'on
a oublié quelque chose maintenant je
suis gaucher contrarié
etonnant non
[Applaudissements]